good morning everyone we'll Now call the
order the commission to study the
purpose of proposing legislation for
State controlled sale of cannabis and
cannabis
products representative P do you wish to
pledge I pledge to the UN States of
America to the repu stands one nation
God
all well I don't know who sits in this
chair but this thing is really pumped up
oh this
is here you're taller than me
exact I don't know how happened
here
well first we got to address does anyone
everyone get a chance to review the
minutes any any
changes I have a question Mr chair on
bullet number on page two bullet number
five and six it seems there's a
contradictory um statement here it
number five says recreational Cannabis
is more affordable number six says
therapeutic products are cheaper because
they are not taxed so I'm confused as to
which is prod that I I understand the
minutes say that but that may have been
the fact that the testimony was
inconsistent okay is the minutes wrong
or was the testimony wrong right I I
guess the I think the were corre the
minutes were correct that's that that's
consistent with my memory too oh okay
thank
you represent who is there issue with
the minutes yes yeah you know bullet
point number two you know it's saying no
general fund dollars go into the program
but they get office spas and electrical
like you know that's General funds well
that was I understand factually you may
not agree with what the minutes say but
was that the test the minutes is
basically summarizes the testimony
whether you agree with the testimony or
not
is we know they're getting general fund
dollars based on getting office space
and but it doesn't change the testimony
that was given so the minutes need to
that's but I think the the the minutes
for this meeting will
reflect what we're talking about right
now actually speaking of
which our Clerk's not
here he um he just said he is in ja car
then was is there is there a volunteer
to take
notes as
want
anyone
you is there a motion to adopt the
minutes yes I
move all those in favor please say I I
all
oppos so I think what we're going to do
uh the purpose of today first I would
like to hear from the Attorney General's
office um so we'll have those Witnesses
may may take the hot seat uh in respect
to the and our reminded when it's a
draft the working draft we'll call it
did everyone on the get a copy of
that who's who's here from the Attorney
General's
office and just for the point of what
we're doing today if we can in the sake
of efficiency we we all know that
cannabis is against federal law
therapeutic Canabis is against federal
law the basically everything in the any
proposed draft is against federal law so
we don't need to really Hammer that out
and emphasize that point any more than I
just did so if we
can move on from that issue and I guess
yours good morning Mr chair uh members
of the commission uh my name is Miles
Madison I'm senior Assistant Attorney
General at the Attorney General's office
and chief of the Criminal jce Justice
Bureau
uh been asked uh today to to speak to
some of the uh the liabilities uh the
state liabilities uh both criminal and
civil uh for uh State involvement or
authorization of uh recreational
Cannabis or marijuana um as part of that
um we had a comment from the chair
regarding uh it being federally legal
just wanted to lay out some of the
Contours uh of that lands Cape uh
because it it does matter from a legal
perspective where there may be
liabilities what sorts of liabilities
there may be um both from the criminal
liability side as well as from uh the
Civil liability side um so would lay out
some aspects of federal marijuana laws
some of the prosecutions that are being
pursued uh by federal authorities uh and
then speak to some uh civil litigation
involving State authorizations or
izations uh of
marijuana um so as you all know
marijuana is currently scheduled as a
schedule one uh controlled substance
under the Controlled Substances Act um
and that like with other schedule one
substances would prohibit the uh
manufacture distribution dispensation
and possession of marijuana except in
federally approved uh context such as
research studies um that prohibition
doesn't just have criminal consequence
quences that has other consequences
under federal law such as uh convictions
or involvement uh rendering one unable
to participate in federal Housing
Programs uh to procure certain visas uh
to have federal employment uh or to uh
participate in in military service uh
there may also be complications for
banking um I know that we have uh
there's some limitations on financial
institutions and how they have to
interact and engage with uh marijuana
related businesses uh there may also be
limitations in the access to federal
grants or federal monies
um as well the the posture of the
federal law sort of depends on two
sources there is the the doj policy
relating to the enforcement of the
Controlled Substances Act and then there
are also annual Appropriations writers
passed by Congress that uh control what
expenditures uh may be utilized or
limits expenditures for the enforcement
of certain marijuana related laws um so
the the the Controlled Substances Act um
and the Appropriations writers only
concern uh the enforcement of the
Controlled Substances Act against
medical
marijuana um regimes so there's
essentially a congressional prohibition
on expending federal resources for
enforcement against uh medically
uh based State
programs the doj posture uh has us doj
posture uh has gone through several
iterations several different memoranda
relating to the enforcement of the
Controlled Substances Act um the
Department of Justice has repeatedly
reaffirmed its position that the growing
manufactured distribution sale of
marijuana is federally illegal it is
enforceable uh and instead Federal
resources would be concentrated on
certain types of violations of the
Controlled Substances Act notably those
relating to uh the illicit marijuana
trade so there have been at various
times different objectives put forward
that concentrate Federal resources on
the prosecutions that that do occur um
and those have been articulated as
preventing that the federal interests
have been preventing marijuana usage by
miners preventing revenue from marijuana
from going to criminal organizations
preventing marijuana as a cover for
other drug dealing preventing violence
around marijuana cultivation and
distribution preventing drugged driving
and then preventing marijuana use or
cultivation on federal
lands uh as I mentioned that the
Congressional prohibition it's been an
annual uh Appropriations writer so
provision um in Appropriations
legislation since since uh fiscal year
2015 uh that has uh essentially as it's
laid out uh is preventing is prohibiting
doj from using appropriated funds uh to
prevent certain States territories or
the District of Columbia from
implementing their own laws that
authorize the use distribution
possession or cultivation of medical
marijuana so again that Appropriations
writer doesn't touch uh non-medical or
recreational uh uses there has been
litigation relating to that writer uh
essentially asserted as a defense in
some criminal
prosecutions
um it has in some circumstances barred
some criminal prosecutions saying No
this Falls within the the uh the
prohibition the US doj is prohibited
from pursuing this enforcement action
because of that Appropriations riter in
other circumstances um that writer has
not prohibited prosecutions indeed there
are approximately a thousand marij
related Federal uh cases prosecuted each
year that number has been declining uh
but it still has
um still has resulted in from those
prosecutions an average prison sentence
of roughly 33 months so uh there are
still prosecutions related to the
Controlled Substances Act and us doj is
pursuing those uh one of the interesting
aspects of of us doj prosecutions uh has
not just been on illicit drug trade what
we might think of as cartel activity
related to uh marijuana trafficking but
also compliance with state regimes so
there have been circumstances where a
failure of individuals to comply with a
well-regulated state regime has resulted
in in criminal prosecutions so it's
essentially operating outside of the the
boundaries of that state system has
resulted in criminal liability and the
US doj has prosecuted that so as one of
the articulated state or or federal
interests uh compliance with a regime if
a state is setting something up then the
state is
uh there may not be criminal
prosecutions related to the uh the use
of marijuana under that state regime but
a failure to comply with that a failure
to oversee that uh can subject
individuals who are not compliant with
that state regime with criminal
liability
the I think it it's fair to say that
it's uh the Federal Criminal
enforcement of the Controlled Substances
Act is is somewhat on a sliding scale uh
it is controlled in one part by uh
Congressional language Appropriations
writers it's controlled uh in another
way by the the mere policy position that
us doj has taken even while the
underlying statutory regime remains
intact that marijuana is federally
prohibited um in in all forms except in
those narrow Federal research
studies there are liabilities criminal
liabilities related to that uncertainty
of that that policy landscape so um
legislatively I won't speak to that but
the the posture of us doj is operating
merely between an Appropriations writer
and a change in policy and how they
approach uh the enforcement of uh the
criminal prohibitions related to to
marijuana and and that line has changed
depending on uh the the policy positions
that us doj has taken uh there are still
uh many prosecutions uh that are are
being pursued and what types of
prosecutions uh are being pursued could
change again based on on the policy of
of us
doj moving to civil liability just want
to speak uh more narrowly of one example
examp Le of what could arise with a a
state authorized or state run marijuana
regime so in August uh a in federal
court was filed a complaint against the
state of New York it's the Cannabis
impact prevention Coalition um at all
versus uh a number of different state
institutions and state officials in New
York um so that was filed in August in
federal court um the the primary
defendants are the New York cannabis
control board the New York office of
cannabis management and then a number of
different state officials including uh
the governor and other senior State
officials the the main thrust of the
lawsuit is challenging the 20121
legalization of
marijuana uh the the language of the the
lawsuit uh that the the plaintiffs are
alleging that the legalization and state
regime uh amounts to uh one of the
largest drug trafficking organizations
uh in the country part of that is the
looking at the state created entities
that would be involved in the Cannabis
regulation um so for example The
dormatory Authority of New York would be
responsible for leasing or approving
Leasing and other locations for uh for
cannabis um entities or businesses um so
as the plaintiffs describe they would be
the chief leasing agent for marijuana
trafficking
locations
um that the the the relief sought under
that lawsuit is uh is federal so it's
saying that there is a preemption
concern here the state regime is illegal
under federal law it's preempted and
unenforceable and so the the relief is
declaratory relief stating that that the
state law conflicts with federal laws to
enjoin the state from spending any money
on the operation of those different
entities the Cannabis control board the
office of cannabis
management uh and to essentially uh
bring that that regime uh to a stop uh
so that that lawsuit was filed in in
August it is pending I I bring it up as
the type of of civil liability uh that
can uh that can come from uh any number
of of challenges to uh State authorized
regimes the speaking more more broadly
the those liabilities whether they are
criminal from uh us doj enforcement
whether they are civil uh civil uh
lawsuits uh that are that are
brought the uniqueness of any particular
regime or structure May
attract some of those liabilities so uh
the most
permissive
uh marijuana regime uh under as a
compares to federal law may be the first
Target for federal prosecutions if there
is a change in policy uh the most
permissive or expansive regime May uh
make it a more likely Target that regime
for civil cases that are testing uh the
efficacy of some of these structures um
relative to the enforcement of federal
law
um so in in summary would just say that
adopting any state
controlled or state managed system
certainly creates liabilities there's
there's no doubt about that both
criminal and civil uh the probability or
extent of those liabilities is unknown
to the Attorney General's office we
can't predict what changes in policy on
the federal side may result in
consequences or liabilities uh for for
State
actors um but again as I mentioned if if
a regime is unique then that May from a
legal perspective create unique
liabilities or increase whatever that
probability is increase that probability
action just uh summarizing again uh
criminal enforcement certainly depends
on the combination of the the ongoing
annual Appropriations writer and the
policy positions of us doj relating to
exercising prosecutorial restraint and
so today I can't speak to the
realization of any of those
probabilities of those liabilities but
would just uh Point them out related to
this commission's consideration uh or
recommendation of legislation with that
that con concludes my uh my testimony
happy to take
questions all right well that was great
that was very informative um I have one
question it's always been bugging me
where everyone says it's you know the
against the law federal you know federal
law about the marijuana being grown
outside a state and imported and in that
list of things you said they did funding
did they have any money funding to
ensure that Mar that uh licensed
controlled marijuana grown in one state
can't cross the state line did they are
they putting any money into it or is
that
enforced I so I think I understand what
you're getting at would be the the US
doj policy
uh focuses for its enforcement actions
and what they're trying to articulate in
pursuing any enforcement um I believe
that
crossborder um crossb movements of
marijuana is one of those components
that that the
federal um authorities are looking at so
I don't know what funding is
specifically allocated or what um
portion of their enforcement activity is
focused on that um
it would probably combine with other
aspects that they're pursuing so for
example the illicit uh marijuana trade
or trafficking
so how that often realizes in criminal
prosecutions maybe what we'd think of as
other drug cartels that are also moving
marijuana as a product so I would look
at that as a number of different factors
that drive prosecutorial decisions or
allocation of resources I don't know
specifically uh what federal FOC or
resources there are uh for mere right
well I guess I'm um to follow so two
things that my take- home here okay is
is that um the feds have decided which
what things they're going to enforce
simply but whether they're going to put
spend money on enforcement and then the
other aspect that really got me today is
that you're saying is that having the
state pass a
statute gives the uh that almost card
blunch for the federal government says
okay now we won't get involved in your
state because you've created this
regulatory authority to allow for
marijuana and to me that opens up a huge
can of worms because what that says is
anything we the state think it's legal
then the federal government says okay
then that can be legal so if we said we
think it's okay someone to import
marijuana from another licensed
manufacturer in a different state you
know like much like we do with liquor
you say then then theoretically the
federal government could potentially say
okay that's fine we're not going to
enforce the cross the state
line so my response to that would be
that it's the uh the allocation of
resources as a prosecutorial discretion
so uh where there is a state regime uh
the I believe that the way that us doj
um has phrased it um in essence is it
would be a poor allocation of of
prosecutorial resources uh where there
is a state regime in place for
uh for many of the the Controlled
Substances Act violation crimes that
they could be prosecuting um that
doesn't mean that uh as I understand the
policy that that would eliminate any
enforcement activities in the state just
may result in a reallocation or refocus
on what uh what prosecutions or
investigations may happen so essentially
deprioritizing certain prosecutions if
there is a regime in place again it
could also as I mentioned uh create some
additional liabilities if there's a lack
of compliance with that state regime so
there have been instances where um
individuals are outside of the bounds
essentially of a state regime and those
individuals have been prosecuted by us
doj because they're not in compliance
with that that regulatory Authority
within the
state
just one moment could we are we
streaming
are
chief thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for your uh testimony today so uh a
few clarifying questions here um today
so
um from your testimony uh the only Cong
prohibition with respect to the
prosecution and enforcement of federal
uh statutes uh extends only to medical
marijuana programs is that an accurate
representation of your testimony on for
with respect to Congressional writers
that's my understanding is that it's an
annual Appropriations writer that limits
that uh expenditures to or prohibits
enforcement related to medical marijuana
yes thank you and so is it fair to say
then that the various doj policies
United States Department of Justice
policies with with respect to how
Department of Justice which would be ATF
FBI DEA US Marshall Service uh
appropriates and spends its money uh is
and how the US attorneys um prioritize
Federal prosecutions is largely then
dependent uh on the various policies
promulgated by the Attorney General of
that Administration would that be fair
to say yes that's correct so then would
it be fair to say then that those
policies could change based on the
administration yes they can and they
have changed the articulation of the the
policy relating to the the enforcement
of the control Substances Act as it
relates to marijuana has changed it's
been modified numerous times over the
past decade thank you and if there were
to be a federal uh or state Tor claim uh
such as one that was recently filed in
New York on your testimony who would
represent uh the state if the state uh
were to be um a defendant in a tort
claim action similar to the one that you
discussed in your testimony uh
ordinarily it would be the State
Attorney General's office who would be
uh responsible for uh responding to and
litigating actions against State
actors um the followup question
um with respect to the Banking and
distribution in Interstate uh Commerce
uh if the state were to pass a
legalization uh regime as you indicated
here in New Hampshire and the state of
New Hampshire uh invested or placed or
comingled proceeds from the revenue
obtained from the sale of marijuana with
other state funds such as retirement
funds alcohol uh um abuse uh funds would
those monies be subject to seizure or
forfeiture uh if there were to be a
challenge made by the federal
government it's my understanding that
they would be in the same way that
there's isn't any prohibition uh against
the enforcement other than policy of the
Controlled Substances Act criminal
violations so um I believe that it would
be under the same posture relating to
um any asset forfeiture of funds related
to the as federal law would describe it
the trafficking of of illegal Controlled
Substances would the state uh attorne
would your office the Attorney General's
office have a um recommendation or a
position with respect to sequestering if
the state were to pass a legalization
regime and obtain proceeds to
sequestering that money and not
comingling it with other funds uh to
protect those other funds from potential
litigation uh the Attorney General's
office doesn't have a specific
recommendation on that today uh would
note just in our discussion of legal
liabilities uh that um managing those
liabilities there are various mechanisms
to do that uh one of those could be
segregation um of funds in order to try
to isolate any liability from
impacting any non-marijuana
related um policies or funding sources
chair thank you Mr chair um just to
follow up on the last I presume then
that the uh commission would like to see
some sort of a example from the uh
Attorney General on how that segregation
would would be
done uh is that
possible that would be very helpful I
leave it to the AG's office if they
would be willing to help us with that
but I I can note that uh request again
just in terms of of posture um the the
structure of the Attorney General's
office there may be if there requests it
may be a client counseling matter um or
a a question a request that uh goes to
someone who may be better positioned to
speak to that than than I am today I
think when and correct me if I'm if I'm
wrong when when
the you testified about the franchise
model I think it was a desire to keep
the money the revenue in its
own section so it wouldn't becomeing
like the revenue from liquor
sales there's already at least a yeah I
would i' would like to see what uh what
the uh AG's office has has broad
guidelines not the exact uh uh
terminology that's our job not uh not
their job but the Brad the guidelines as
to how and that could be set up that
that's the follow question that I still
Reserve questions yes
repres kale I'll just have a follow-up
question on this this line of subject um
you know in the proposed legislation
there's the talk of the 1% going to
certain municipalities I mean I think
those same towns would have to worry
about segregating the money possibly too
um just just an idea to look into that
on that but we could we could cut a I
know with Alaska with some of their oil
sales they send money back to the people
directly we could send it back to this
the residents of the state then we all
have to do it
that but yeah I see what you're saying
that could be a problem I I um and I but
I do have one question um thank thank
you for your testimony it was really
really great testimony I think it was
helpful to to a lot of us here but I I I
was interested in this New York case is
your office following this New York case
uh yes now uh we are so I think that
we'll it it's one example of other
civilization in this area um I uh I'm
not conversent with all of the the civil
litigation related to this to to be
blunt but yes we'll be following this
case you know obviously there would be a
cost to the taxpayers if if we got s
sued in that way do you do you have an
idea of how much this litigation is
going to cost the state of New York um I
don't uh it probably would be public
should it proceed just because
attorney's fees are requested uh so that
may be part if there is any if it's
successful in any way then then there
may be some indication there um I would
note just generally that litigation
expenses would depend on um the scope of
the litigation uh and you know
individual factors such as what is being
challenged so uh that's hard to predict
in terms of any kind of of costs
relating to to
litigation repres
Sol thanks for your testimony it was uh
super helpful so I my understanding is
that franchises or or franchises are
generally regul ated by the federal
franchising like they have a whole fed
Federal franchising rule how would that
impact the state of New Hampshire in
terms of us regulating something here in
a franchise model and then having it
having to be over reg or regulated on
top of that by the the federal
government like do you guys have any
position or any idea how that might work
and would it matter that all of our
franchisees would be within the states
so maybe it would be a unique situation
where it wouldn't matter whereas say
McDonald's it's everywhere so that's why
it's a federal regulatory
framework I don't know on that that
specific example that's something I can
uh take a look at
um going back to to one of the aspects
that is a challenge in this and it may
be similar in the the franchise um
context would be banking so Financial
transactions uh certainly complicated um
with a Divergence between state
authorization and and federal law so um
I different states have adopted
different uh legal structures relating
to uh what Financial transactions or
structures may be uh permitted uh but I
believe it's fair to say that there
there is an uh compliance burden related
to uh that disconnect between state and
federal law relating to to banking um it
may be the same with a a franchise model
or oversight I I don't know to answer
that specifically today yeah I know I I
I'm not a lawyer by any means and I
don't know the details of it but I
thought that was kind of a peculiar part
of this because if if its franchises are
generally regulated at the federal level
then I could see that potentially being
a conflict that maybe we haven't thought
about in this committee and I think
that's something we should probably dig
into because yeah um so another question
would be and I don't know if you even
know how to to think about this I don't
know the details of this case aside from
probably what every in this room knows
but like I'm
thinking we all remember when that woman
sued McDonald's because she burnt
herself with Co got you know spilled the
coffee and got burnt right if something
were to happen in a State
Franchise because we're calling it a
franchise we're not calling it like a
license or we're not calling it you know
whatever um is the state liable for
something that happens in that store I
mean I would imagine if in in the
alcohol commission if something happens
in that store they can sue the alcohol
commission which is part of the state
would we would we have liability to
somebody in a franchise messing up in
some way selling something that makes a
kid sick or die or something like that
and then the state is on the hook not
just that local franchisee I I mean
maybe I don't know if it's a good
analogy but the McDonald's example with
the coffee I think they tried to sue the
the actual Corporation not just that
franchise that sold the coffee I'm
curious how that might might expose the
state to some sort of risks that we
maybe haven't thought
of so what that makes me think of would
be um what liabilities would would flow
to any individual actors or entity let's
say in the location that you're speaking
of so a a uh you know a franchised store
uh and whether there would be State
liabilities
um could depend on what uh rules uh have
been issued what regulations what
structure so someone could potentially
challenge uh the underlying
authorization of a particular way of
handling a product or um uh of the the
State Management not just any error um
or liability created by an individual or
an individual store so um that wouldn't
be unique of trying to attach liability
for um what a plaintiff would claim as a
flawed regime so there's a problem in in
the rules or the statute and so the
plaintiff could seek relief um for an
injury that occurred under that
regulation or
statute thank you so much and just a
little just from information the
McDonald's case what really spiked that
that um my torz law professor was
lectured us on this for a whole class
and what happened was McDonald's was
notified that the coffee they were
serving was well
was heated well beyond like the industry
standard but also this was a long time
ago they didn't have warning labels
saying this may be Hut so when you would
get coffee you expect it to be hot but
around 130 they were serving it around
170 so the expectation of the consumer
was different so there was a couple
things that played into that so maybe if
a contaminated product was sold out of a
franchise store that maybe the
franchisee is not the one that
manufactured that or knew it was
contaminated would they still be liable
might be the and you don't have to
answer that today but if you can get us
set information obviously the
manufacturer could face liability but
think of like a supermarket if they had
a contaminated produce if they didn't
know was contaminated would they be
liable you'd still have to follow
standard Tor law as far as the
investigation of the armm as to who
caused the harm so the state may or may
not be depending upon what role State
played if any yes and but the thing is
with McDonald's they were notified by
several consumer there was other
injuries prior to that where they were
notified of the problem and they I think
the evidence was that they they ignored
it which made it
punitive that's spiked the
damages right but just to say if if
McDonald's required it to be at a higher
temperature then it would have been the
rule was the problem and so therefore
they would have had a legitimate case
but because McDonald's didn't have any
requirement or it was only industry
standard that's why it may not have it
but you're you're saying this lawsuit
was pursued because they had been
informed prior to that that there was a
problem of hot water I think that that
cause punitive damage is to make the
Judgment multiplied several times over
because they were aware of the problem
when you have knowledge of a problem
right if someone if a franchise he sold
a product they knew was contaminated and
that led to some type of injury I mean
that's that's game can't he couldn't use
federal law on this it would be strictly
under New Hampshire law so you'd have to
meet the New Hampshire law requirements
for communitive damages which are uh you
got to be stupid
to gain them we don't have trip no we
don't have Massachusetts but just to to
follow up
on fortunately that's I've been involved
in several of those Massachusetts ones
you can get a lot of money in that um
the DJ uh uh
is undertaking a a selective enforcement
type thing Pro prosec pural discretion
which makes no sense but
um what jurisdiction do they have on a
non-commerce clause about
inate
Commerce where we're limited this to
inside State of New Hampshire it's it
analogous to what Minnesota was it
Minnesota well one of the northern
states maybe it was Dakota did with the
gun Manufacturing exempting themselves
from Guns by manufacturing it all within
the state if we're maintaining are
growing in sales only within New
Hampshire how does the doj get involved
at
all so I'm not sure that I can answer
specifically that that question that the
um I I think that necessarily but
DEA can't have marijuana DEA would call
and say want you but it it goes back to
the it goes It goes to the core of the
issue what right does the federal
government have to control what product
is grown where they
don't that's a tenth that's a 10 you
can't have the product in your
possession yeah but that they they only
have the the federal government
under the Constitution only has
interstate commerce you know that John
and then and then you have many many
times then you have the 10th Amendment
that comes into play where the hell does
doj get off regulating what happens
inside of a
state so what I would say to that
generally is that uh the um the extent
of
prosecutions
um I don't I don't it doesn't seem as as
as if there was a bar merely relying on
that that distinction uh and there uh it
appears that there are are doj
prosecutions that have proceeded for a
number of years uh that that may depend
entirely or be uh fact specific where
cannabis may be grown within a state and
there may be other factors that have
prosecution it should be no surprise
that the federal government's position
on marijuana regulations is very
inconsistent I mean it's part of the
mess that the states are facing now and
what we're dealing with today is they
pick and choose which ones they want to
enforce which ones they don't and you
can see that's that's problematic in
other areas too so just to follow up on
that for half a second uh going back to
the co-mingling of funds New Hampshire
has a a rather interesting structure of
um taxation for business businesses uh
we have the BET and the BPT under the in
the 70s
um would that be co-mingling of funds if
we charged the BET employee tax and a
business profits tax on a franchise that
was selling a quote illegal
product sir that's outside of my area of
expertise I don't have an answer for you
apologize
no you're you're right no listen there's
a lot there's a several problems here I
get
it thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I have a question
regarding the the um Federal doj
discretionary um
prosecutorial um stance it it so if I'm
understanding this correctly um the um
non-compliance with State statue May
activate um Federal prose ution
regarding a controlled substance act
however um you know violation of federal
law uh is dependent on the discretion of
doj their funding discretion whether
they would follow up on a controlled
substance act violation of the law I
don't know that they have any
independent uh sources there or there
would be a distinction so in terms of
USD J's articulation of where it will
concentrate resources it's my
understanding that non-compliance with a
state regime is a
factor along with other factors that
they consider in pursuing a prosecution
so I don't know that it has a unique
Authority for pursuing
non-compliance uh but there have been
several cases in in the the ninth
circuit also in the the first circuit uh
where there have been prosecutions
brought uh the defendants were
essentially trying to defend the the
prosecution by uh stating that there was
a uh a the Appropriations riter would
prohibit utilization of funds for those
enforcement actions and the courts have
have uh said No it's it's limited uh the
Appropriations riter does not prohibit
all prosecutions this would still be a
violation of the Controlled Substances
Act and so therefore um us doj has the
discretion to bring charges but the the
non-compliance with the state regime in
those sorts of cases I think would only
be a factor uh impacting us doj's
enforcement action there's no
requirement or I don't think that it
would be a um any unique Authority that
non-compliance with the state regime
would lead to an enforcement
action I just said um um the doj of
course would have no uh interaction or
involvement in civil liability
correct are you speaking about the us
doj or the Attorney General's off New
Hampshire Attorney General's office us
doj for example in the New York uh case
that was uh discussed earlier um there
would be no involvement of the US doj or
would there no I don't believe that
they're uh a party to that lawsuit it's
uh the lawsuit uh claim is dependent on
federal law but uh aren't named
plaintiffs or defendant in that in that
case okay and and the opposite is true
right the New York the New York doj is
defending State that's correct in
respect to this case out of New
York it's it's a private or nonprofit or
entity that's bringing the lawsuit as
the plaintiff and what essentially is
the theory of that are they trying to
get compel the state to comply with
Federal I guess what's
there so it would be a collection I'm uh
I'm forgetting the total number of uh
named plaintiffs it would be several
different organizations as well as a
number of different individuals in the
State uh so the
the claims um or the petition for Relief
is really uh based on two things one
would be to um have a declaratory
judgment a statement saying New York law
is inconsistent with federal law and it
is
unenforceable uh and then to prohibit
any state action based on that uh that
unenforceability to say this is uh
federal law preempts New York law and
therefore New York cannot spend any
resources any Appropriations in order to
enforce or operate its own U marijuana
related regulatory structure and not to
put you in the spot but it put that in
another context like immigration could
someone file same type of lawsuit
against a state that had Sanctuary
cities I mean it seems to me it's kind
of the reverse the federal government
normally can't compel the states to
comply with they law is what I always
that's how the Supreme Court ruled on
that issue so I'd say that there's
there's a lot of civil litigation
relating to uh uh State regimes and
State Legal structures so um when a any
legislature patches legislation uh there
may be groups individuals in a similar
structure as with this new York uh
lawsuit that will bring a lawsuit
against the state or different state
entities uh or actors uh to try to
enjoin them from uh enforcing or from
pursuing or managing uh the statutory uh
requirements so that's that is not
unique that happens in many different uh
issue areas and do you not again not to
put you in the spot but I am has the
courts ruled on any not related to
Canabis what was their rulings in
respect to that when a individual
tries to compel a state to comply with
federal
law
um I don't have a great answer here I'd
say that it's really fact specific and
where there where there is a preemption
uh issue or where they're able to show
preemption uh then that would enjoin the
enforcement or administration of state
law uh that that does happen regularly
in different spheres uh so for example
uh in campaign Finance law there may be
a state uh State Statute that is
inconsistent with a or consistent with a
federal statute and if the federal
statute uh preempts explicitly or
implicitly any state action in that
field then a plaintiff could sue in
order to to block or prohibit any state
action based on that state law so U it's
certainly not unique to um to to the
topic of marijuana it happens routinely
in other areas as well and in respect to
I guess the Doomsday scenario would be
we pass legislation it becomes law there
retail
stores throughout the state and then the
FED federal government comes in
and shuts them down I guess right so
that in order for that to come to to
happen would that require federal law
enforcement officers with a DA FBI they
would have to come in and actually
enforce their federal marijuana
laws presumably any enforcement action
would would look similar to current
enforcement actions uh by federal
authorities so involvement of DEA other
entities and us doj uh Prosecuting those
cases bringing those cases forward and
is there any I guess distinction between
why that would happen in New Hampshire
versus Maine
Massachusetts any other state that has
retail stores right now California I
mean I guess I be curious why the feds
would come to New Hampshire shut down
the retail stores and not the other
states are doing
it so I just point to the the the the
uniqueness aspect so uh whether it is a
civil liability whether it is a criminal
liability um an action uh or regime or
entity that stands out from any others
there may be additional Le legal
liability from that I can't predict
whether any uniqueness uh would lead to
a particular
uh increase in a liability just saying
that ordinarily any uh conduct that is
um more severe or more advanced than
than others may cross that line for uh
the prosecutorial discretion or or
exercise of enforcement action or if it
is a unique legal structure uh may make
it more uh more prone to litigation on
the Civil front as well so um I
certainly don't have an answer on the
likelihood of that happening
uh just doing something new uh May
create new liabilities without knowing
whether those liabilities May ever be
realized it sounds like there's a
potential that the federal government
would be more upset that the state being
involved in selling an illegal drug then
but they're okay with private citizens
selling the illegal
drug even though it's legal I would see
it the other way is that we're actually
going farther in controlling
it than the other states have and so
therefore they we would be the poster
trial what they would want other states
to do because they if they're in the end
of the day I'll I'll go to the when the
repeal of the prohibition and when some
states decide to be control States and
some do not it was the control State
model the whole purpose was this is how
we're going to ensure that alcohol won't
be abused and so therefore I would say
the same thing our model means that we
actually a more control over the safety
and distribution of the product than any
other state and so therefore the federal
government would think we're the best of
all the bunch and I agree with you and
that's very good logic but you're
dealing with an illogical system with
the problem but I makes makes U perfect
sense to me Chief thank you Mr chair um
with respect to having the Attorney
General's office in addition to looking
at the exposure of Co mingling cannabis
proceeds with other state funds your
point with respect to an analogy which I
thought was uh excellent with respect to
McDonald's in that the
corporation um that was setting the
limit for the temperature would be
analogous perhaps to State legislation
in New Hampshire setting a THC limit
that was extraordinarily high that led
to addition cannabis use disorder which
could expose the state to liability
based on its regulation so perhaps the
Attorney General's office um in
connection with our efforts may look
further and deeper into how regulations
May expose the state to liability with
respect to civil tort actions as a
result of that
regulation just to follow up on that
perhaps I think a key would be what the
warning legal sense something when it's
the consumer is aware of the side
effects you know you can't if this says
this will cause this or may cause that
and then they use the product and that
side effect happens the disclosure I
think would at least mitigate liability
perhaps maybe a recommendation on a or
on a warning label that would limit
liability in that context I I can note
that request well um Point well taken
but um as as you know um as a barrister
people can bring tort actions for for
just about anything and uh and often do
right and so I think that the the the
surgical point that I'm trying to get to
is the effective regulation much like
your McDonald's case that exposed that
Corporation because it knew that it set
the temperature and allowed that to
happen and there was a risk uh resulted
in that settlement of course civil
juries have their own mind and will do
what they do but I think that going
forward in this process it behooves the
state to have our attorneys by way of
the Attorney General's office uh perhaps
flush out uh the liability risk um um if
they could along with the co-mingling uh
issue that would be my my recommendation
or request but remember the hc's have
have no
limits it they may have but that doesn't
preclude that there could not be a u a
Tor action that um that someone could
claim so uh simply the absence of an
occurring thank you Mr chair I'm just
trying to wrap my brain around this and
um um can you check my understanding uh
I've summarized this as anyone who
participates in the growing possession
manufacturer distribution or sales of
recreational Cannabis under state law or
Aids and or facilitates or finances such
actions is at risk of federal
prosecution or other a liability from
harmed parties is that
correct what you just described appears
to be a violation of the Controlled
Substances Act and a violation of
federal law thank
you thank you Mr chair would it be
possible for your office to put together
some information on that New York case
so so that we had it for our packets and
oh you sorry I I can send that uh that
case uh around and follow up as as we're
consideration thank you yeah so I guess
more just directing you but hopefully
the AG's office will look into the
franchise thing more more broadly
because it certainly seems possible
that a court could rule and again I'm
not a lawyer so I going pretend like I I
really understand the legal the legal
framework why this would happen but it
seems possible that a court could rule
that the state is in a cons is working
with a franchisees and conspiracy to
commit a federal crime because the
franchising the franchising framework is
governed at the federal level not the
state level and so I think that that
seems like a part that I mean I know you
haven't looked at yeah but if if we
could get some if you guys could maybe
give us some sort of an opinion on that
I think that would be really helpful for
me because it seems to me like this is
when he talks about the uniqueness of
this model potentially opening us up to
different types of enforcement this
seems like the way that it could happen
or the most obvious way and I think we
should understand that before we we jump
into it without exploring that I I think
you basically just to rephrase your
question would the state actors whether
it's the folks working in the Liquor
Commission whether it's liquor
enforcement are they could they be
charged with conspiracy with if the
retail store is because they're helping
facilitate that and because they're
profiting off it and they Yeahs working
together uh under like just basic
conspiracy know
101 I would lean into the yes but yeah I
me just saying like how can how can a
state employee fulfill their obligations
under state law while simultaneously
violating the laws of the federal law I
think I I'm not a lawyer so I can't I
really come up with a good theory but it
seems to me that the regulatory
framework around franchises
specifically seems like this could be a
problem for us that we should definitely
try to understand it so from and I can
just speak on that with an understanding
is you're you're correct a state
employee a liquor enforcement officer
would essentially there will be times if
they're dealing with um cannabis could
be violating the federal law U I think
that that's one of the concerns that's
kind of come up throughout the
process uh again that would require the
federal government now to come here and
arrest a state employee or you know one
of our law enforcement officers and
charge them with that you know charged
with with violating law so again that
would require the feds to come in and do
it but I think you're correct I I would
point out why I'm very when I look at
this is I use the term it's been a joke
you can go on you know Fidelity and buy
shares in a cannabis company on your
cell phone all right and that that's
International that's state lines that's
Bank issues that's wiring you name it
it's there so again where where's the
federal government with that I mean they
they're the problem we face is we have
to guess what they'll do and what they
want W do and I think for us for me if
they're going to do something and Target
just this state I I think that that's I
guess but I think I think my point is if
there we are we are at some level
creating a business that will be
regulated by the feds whereas if we had
a truly private based model it wouldn't
be regulated by the feds it would be
regulated just by the state that's sort
of my my
question okay so
uh Google right Cornell Law don't worry
about it the we will be in compliance
with the federal law the federal law is
all about
disclosure that we must there are
certain disclosures about fees and
regulations and how they might lose
their license and I can assure you that
when we offer up a franchise agreement
we'll have no trouble being compliance
with the federal
law that's good I mean I think the law
is probably more than you were able to
read really quickly on Google what
spefically says the violation of it is
if you didn't disclose it might be good
to just get AG's opinion on is all I'm
asking for I would welcome our federal
delegation to also chime in if they ever
want to offer some guidance on what's
going on at the federal level with this
because again a lot of the confusion and
what ifs is to the inaction at the
so that was
great thank you for your testimony thank
you want to take a five minutes okay so
what do we have
nexts I think we'll just be we're going
minutes
the show on the road are there any
representatives from the atcs that are
here
today and to our our friends in the atcs
I know there might be more than one but
I would welcome you to kind of come up
two thank you thank you Mr chairman do
we have more
coming
but we only have two chairs right here
so if it please the committee or
commission I'll I'll introduce our
guests and uh we'll introduce ourselves
and the individuals we have behind us
we'll we'll pull up a
chair yeah I'll take care of Dy can can
for so the individuals behind us may
have very little to say on specific
topics so yes we want them to be
needed all right this will make a great
group
photo one big happy family one big happy
family and thank you for coming in and
if each of you can just uh identify your
name and if you're here on behalf of an
organization what organization you're on
behalf of thank you Mr chairman so for
the record my name is Matt Simon I work
for granite Leaf cannabis uh formerly
Prime ATC
and the director of government and
public relations uh we have two
dispensaries one in Chichester one in
Peterboro uh good morning everybody my
name is Brandon poock I'm the board
chair of tamascal Wellness uh we operate
uh therapeutic dispensaries in Lebanon
keen and do with a manufacturing
hello my name is Dr David Sak I'm the
medical director for Sanctuary ATC we
operate cannabis dispensaries in
Plymouth and Conway and cultivation site
in
Rochester my name is Keenan Blum I'm the
CEO of granite Leaf cannabis um once
again with locations in marac triester
for dispensaries and a production
facility in Peterboro we employ about 50
New Hampshire
residents Dan you want to screw this up
yeah uh my name is Dan Smith I'm vice
president at vs strategies of public
policy consulting firm that does
business with a lot of different
cannabis businesses and has worked with
uh cannabis Regulators like the Vermont
cannabis control board in the past and
before again uh doctor uh are you did
M so if it pleases the commission I've
been appointed to deliver this unified
testimony we have been collaborating to
develop this so we could all be singing
from the same Himel uh if you
will and there I've given you three
documents uh one is our written unified
testimony uh one is simply a one-pager
uh describing patient education and
support services offered by Granite Leaf
cannabis uh since there were a number of
questions about that at the last meeting
and the third thing is a data report
that was produced by Mr Smith behind us
at our request to be responsive the
questions that have been raised
throughout this process and by the study
commission regarding the experience of
medical cannabis programs and other
states following the Advent of adult use
legalization so as the study commission
considers policy options for integrating
the therapeutic canvas program with the
proposed franchise model we appreciate
the opportunity to provide testimony and
comment on draft
language uh the tcps have been
operational for more than seven years
together we have combined over 20 years
experience producing and dispensing
cannabis in a heavily regulated
environment our teams have worked hard
to Pioneer responsible cannabis industry
in New Hampshire and we would like to
contribute our experience to the
important task of pioneering a
responsible adult use cannabis industry
as well uh we appreciate the concerns
that have been expressed
regarding how this could potentially
impact our program and the patients we
serve so the good news uh after
reviewing And discussing the most recent
draft legislation the atc's all agree
that this uh franchise model can work
for New Hampshire uh we are confident
that the model can be successfully
integrated with the
TCP and uh successful integration
between those two programs We Believe
would help enable a timely and efficient
roll out of the adult use Market while
maintaining and potentially improving
service to registered patients so uh
we've got a few points I'll I'm not
going to read them all I will roll roll
through them and um as efficiently as
possible so the first point is the
inclusion of the for-profit conversion
language that is in this draft and we
appreciate it being there uh this is
language that has passed the legislature
uh the House and Senate uh twice before
as a standalone bill it was included in
HP 639 uh which passed the house this
year and got 10 votes in the Senate was
also in the proposed amendment to S sp98
so it's been in all the models that have
been presented so far I feel that we may
not need to blavor this point unless
people have questions um but the
nonprofit requirement has presented many
obstacles to developing a successful
program and uh a lot of people don't
realize this but the atc's are required
to be nonprofits at the state level
however we're not nonprofits at the
federal level the IRS does not uh view
us as nonprofits they view us as as
you've already heard illicit drug
dealers so there are no advantages to
the nonprofit status tax-wise and in
fact we we have to uh we're not able to
take the normal business deductions that
are available to pretty much any other
type of business
so um we believe this is essential to us
being able to expand and serve the adult
use Market I think that's an issue that
we should have our federal delegation
address as well that would be I would
certainly
agree so yeah second Point uh can the
atcs operate within two different
regulatory structures can we serve two
masters if you will yes I we believe we
can uh and some other examples that came
to mind were convenience stores which
depending on what they sell have to
report to several different government
entities um banks are regulated by the
banking department but they may offer
Financial
Services uh that cannot be collocated
with the tellers but have to be in a
separate part of the bank and they're
licensed by the insurance department
Andor the Bureau of Securities
regulation I'm no expert on any of that
but I I seemed like somewhat similar to
what we're talking about with
potentially dual use cannabis um it can
be done
um what's needed is clear rules and a
clear understanding of what the respon
regulatory responsibilities are and
we're confident that can be figured out
through this process and dialed in
further during the rul making
process uh what's essential is that
atc's do are able to transition smoothly
and serve both the adult use and
therapeutic markets without phing facing
unnecessary burdens uh and I don't know
what an unnecessary burden is off the
top of my head but if that's the only
faar with dual Regulators if you had two
uh Regulators trying to regulate the
same plant and they disagree on how to
do that so back to rules and making sure
that there are not conflicts in the
rules um so we appreciate that the draft
Bill requires uh the nhslc to con
consult with the HHS uh When developing
rules it's on page 12 we think this is a
good start uh we believe it could be
improved by adding more specific
language to clarify the division of
regulatory responsibilities if the
commission chooses to recommend a dual
regulatory system and we would be more
than happy to work with you uh to
develop appropriate language on that if
I if I could just ask when it comes to
that um is there any thought among and
I'll welcome anyone to answer that
respond to this if all the regulatory
was U Under The Liquor
Commission so in in that scenario uh we
that is potentially workable um I think
the concern that you will hear from some
I'm not saying it's a con a reason not
to do it that we're expressing here the
concern you will hear from some is that
the patient education and support
services the medical aspects of the
program uh could be compromised in that
scenario I'm not saying they would be I
think there would be a the details would
matter a lot on that but from our
perspective it's possible and uh we
would not preclude that that option if
if that's where uh the general court
wants wants to go with this we're we're
happy to discuss those
details
um it's more like reassigning what's
there what's right now that they're
under DHHS but if it was all under just
liquor would that be something that
could be worked with it is an option
believe so point three how should atcs
be integrated with the adult use
regulatory system so we've seen two two
models presented for the study
commission
uh the draft bill that we have would
allow atcs to operate dual use cannabis
retail stores that would exist alongside
the franchise model but the ATC
themselves would not be franchise stores
and we believe that could be a workable
model uh the commission's also discussed
the possibility of dual use stores being
co-branded and included in the franchise
model so for example a retail store
having New Hampshire cannabis Outlet
sign and a granite Leaf cannabis sign or
or whatever and people would recognize
that that's both an adult use and a
therapeutic facility uh I believe that's
consistent with uh the nhslc
presentation As I understood it U and we
believe that could be a
workable system uh regardless of of of
which model whether we're defined as
franchise stores or defined as
independent
retailers uh these options both would
allow us to serve patients and
non-patients from the same facilities
dual use dispensaries are very common
and successfully operated in other
states um and there are some best
practices there and they're generally
already included in this bill uh to
ensure that the dispensaries continue to
serve Patients First and that we
continue to prioritize their needs and I
I see it says co-branding and I
understand right now like today there's
you have the brand for your I I know you
guys is prime I know you Chang your name
but but just Prime because it's no
longer a brand right that's the sign
would say Prime but if you coexisted in
operated dual store it would have the
New Hampshire franchise store and Prime
so I guess I guess for my concern from a
branding perspective for purposes of New
Hampshire for the New Hampshire store it
would the ATC stores would have kind of
a they would be different than the other
franchises I guess who aren't in the ATC
business so I think when it comes to
branding is the long-term Vision perhaps
the product that Prime is producing
I mean that's the individual brand like
here has a boted water it's brand they
don't they don't open their own store
they find a retailer to sell the water
so I guess your the products can still
be therapeutic grade or made by the
company but do they have to have their
own stand on store because I think you
know Jack Daniels is not they don't open
up their own store they sell it same way
right is that the long-term vision of
how this could go because that might
make the Dual license and the the Dual
franchises and and all that you want to
have confusion amongst the public now
you can still Market of having a
therapeutic employee that is knowledge
on the product I'm not going to use the
term expert until I'm convinced that
they're an expert but you understand
where I'm going with this right yeah I
do that work yeah thank you for that
that question so uh is it part of of the
long-term Vision it it has not been up
up to this point part of the long-term
Vision I we have three different
companies that have retail operations
which are branded retail operations uh
two of them have been operating uh
retail serving patients only but retail
under that brand for seven years uh
Granite Leaf we did just change her name
but we we changed our name in part
because we wanted to have a name that
reflected our commitment to New
Hampshire and that did a better job
reflecting what we do so could we give
up that branding of our stores and
become New Hampshire cannabis Outlets
only from
from at least from the public view
driving by I think that is an option
that that we could we would be open to
discussing but it's it's a big ask to to
say you have this retail brand and uh
you're getting rid of it so we're we're
open that to that to that
possibility um but
it's that's that's and I would further
comment that's not what I when I read
the drap bill that's not what I see
because the atcs would not be franch
stores in as I read this draft they
would be separately defined as
independent cannabis retail stores so
that would be different language and
we'd be happy to review that language
and and and comment on it but I don't
think we've seen a bill that would do
that and what I was I'm just thinking in
my head and and you it's up to I would
ask for everyone to tell me if this
makes sense or not if you have your own
branded product you know in theory it
could be sold out of any retail store in
the state now you may have a therapeutic
grade
product and I and I would kind of think
that that the entities that could
manufactur those would be limited to the
ones that exist today so there is what
I'm concerned about is having unfair
Market advantages for if you had some
retail stores that had the ATC inside it
versus the ones who don't so you got to
you got to balance that both ways now if
a store doesn't want to sell the
therapeutic product and I would leave
that to the manufacturers who are
manufacturing that therapeutic grade
they want to have requirements of the
retail what they are comfortable with if
they're going to sell it because it's
going to have a higher dose perhaps
that's the choice that they make those
are all business business decisions
right but I think if you did it that way
it would still allow an increased market
share because now your the therapeutic
product we sold
everywhere right but the person to B
purchase that would still need the
therapeutic card it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be able to be purchased for
recreational purposes does that make
sense that does make sense um when it
works or not it's another store well I I
think it can work um we've I mean
patients would certainly appreciate more
access points to therapeutic canas there
are only seven dispensaries in the state
so the reality of that is a lot of
patients live closer to an adult use
store in Maine or Massachusetts or
Vermont than they do to an ATC I mean it
it would it would be beneficial if we
could get more access to more patients
um I we addressed this issue in HB
639 uh in an attempt to create a fair
transition that would not that would
integrate the atc's in a fair way and
allow plenty of room for new business uh
the concept in HB 639 that we use which
I'm just throwing out as a possible
option to consider um it called a
therapeutic cannabis endorsement and any
adult use retake ER that wanted
to uh agree to go comply with the DHHS
rules for dispensing patient education
and support Etc they could apply for
that therapeutic cannabis endorsement
and be authorized to sell a registered
patients uh not otherwise now I think
what what you're suggesting is is is a
model where any franchise store would be
able to sell to patients and I think
that would that would maximize access
relative to the previous model I think
the one concern you'll hear there and I
think it's a concern that we can we
could we could certainly address um is
simply the education and support
services um
so ways that we could potentially do
that our concern is that somebody who is
battling a serious medical condition
will walk into a franchise store and say
I have cancer I need treatment for this
and if they walk into the atcs and we'll
get to this in our presentation and and
Dr C can can tell you how we handle that
when when people walk in and how we
offer free we offer consultations we
recommend that all patients do I I guess
I could just hit that very briefly uh at
Gran Leaf we we we encourage all
patients to do an initial
consultation uh if the certifying
medical provider provides guidance to
the atc's regarding how to serve a
specific patient we're actually required
by rule to uh follow any instructions or
recommendations provided by the
qualifying patients certifying provider
we're more than happy to cooperate with
them is the certified provider a doctor
yes is a doctor an APRN or it could be a
physician assistant operating under a
doctor's supervision yes so in an Ideal
World all medical professionals would be
educated about cannabis and its
potential therapeutic uses fortunately
we don't live in that Ideal World uh the
research has been incredibly limited
since the 1930s until very recently and
so the reality is most patients who come
to an ATC do not have specific
recommendations from their provider so
the responsibility falls on the atcs to
fill this void by providing education
and support so we employ a grant leave
two patient Educators one at each
location uh one of our patient Educators
is our education supervisor she's
completed several educational courses
including a course called medical
cannabis education for medical providers
offered by the skag School of Pharmacy
at University of Colorado and she's also
a cancer survivor and very passionate
about ensuring that our staff and the
patients we serve are well in informed
regarding the potential benefits and
risks so some of our other staff have
have completed educational courses as
well our education super supervisor uh
undertakes the task of ensuring that all
of our staff are educated on at least
some level and we really do have a
significant number of patients who want
many consultations they've never tried
cannabis before they come in they they
try it they try the first thing it it
works a little bit or may you know they
come back again and they want to talk
more and should I increase my dosage
should I reduce it should should I try
different type of product we're willing
to to talk to them as often as they want
to talk to us we'll do that via phone
we'll do that via Zoom we'll do that via
inperson meetings and it's an aspect of
our mission that we take very seriously
so we also offer classes for patients
there have our fall education Series
going on right now there's a class every
other Thursday on Zoom uh we have a
monthly support group and we maintain a
wide range of informational handouts uh
both online and at the dispensaries so
the question would be what happens when
a patient uh who who comes in for the
first time to a franchise store perhaps
isn't registered and is asking medical
type questions so one option could be
that the atcs make themselves available
and willing to uh yeah happy to take a
question yeah thank you um as a
certifying provider I I I know that
patients uh give me feedback that the
people the atcs are very knowledgeable
um and have a lot of really helpful
information so I I definitely can attest
that patient's value that service um
what I I think maybe what you were
getting to and what I'm wondering is you
know if there is this collocation how
would that work because I I agree I
think that seems like an important
component for patients who are uh
certified uh for medical candidate how
would you be able to continue to provide
that service in this collocation with a
franchise I mean um if I mean both if it
were a collocation and also sort of what
the chairman was talking about if like
it was more like providing your own
product within a larger franchise system
or selling your product without being a
collocation okay so to clarify you're
asking about our dispensary locations
how would we be able to
operate within I get within a FR
franchise obviously I know how it
happens now um but but how would that
work both in the situation of a
collocation as well as if the product
was sold and sort of medically certified
but without being a collocation of the
ATC how do you envision that would work
yeah so I think in terms of of our
dispensaries it would be pretty similar
to how dual use uh Works in in lots of
other states we would have separate
counters or a separate section of the
store that is for adult use and is
branded that way uh we would have a a
counter that's specifically for patients
and we can and should adopt rules that
require the atcs to prioritize patients
if we have limited product we serve
patients first if there's a line we make
sure the patient line isn't long that
people who are not patients can wait in
line but patients should not be so I I
think some of that language is already
in the draft bill I think it was
modified from HB 639 and previous bills
and those are important principles to
make sure we fully intend to continue
serving patients to the best of our
ability but we would like to see
statutory language and rules that
require us to do that in a reasonable
manner as far as how would it work at
other stores that's that's the question
that I I think needs to be answered when
somebody does need education and support
and walks into a franchise store that is
not an
ATC who you going to call so one option
would be to have the atc's participate
in that we're happy to do these
consultations again via phone and zoom
so uh that's one option if some other
entity could spring up and give gred
advice to patients that would be
wonderful um but we want to make sure
that that does we don't create a void
there uh by sending patients with
serious medical conditions to an adult
use system without adequate support and
and guidance does that make sense yeah
uh the in terms of how this is
functioned in other co-use locations in
other states um I I sort of wonder about
you know the different limitations that
we place on adult use that I'm sure will
happen and versus the ones that are much
uh more generous for the medical use
population like how has that worked in
other states in terms of like having
limited counter a be very different from
limited counter B like that seems like
that could be challenging I mean yeah I
I mean it
would let Brandon take this yeah I'll
take this one um our team
manages uh dispensaries in Massachusetts
that have both medical and adult use
operations in the same building um so
essentially you have a couple of
different ways to differentiate that
first as Matt mentioned you have a
separate separate line sometimes a
separate entrance for patients so they
go right up to a different sales counter
where the staff there is trained uh to a
higher level than your general retail
staff um the main difference in products
are higher strength edible products um
that are available to patients and those
um are tracked in a separate electronic
inventory control system and physically
separated from the recreational
inventory and then the other main
difference is there's no no sales tax um
on medical products but um you know
essentially it's it's both physical and
virtual separation of the inventory to
to differentiate the products from the
recreational side so I know there's been
a lot of concern that came up last or
last session about you know how what the
potential impact of adult use could be
on the cost of medical cannabis product
prods um would the sort of Maintenance
of cost uh in this model be that you
know if the atcs were involved in adult
use franchising that that just helps
keep the cost neutral and then the adult
use products have likely a significant
tax and then there's no ta like how are
we because I know there was a lot of
question Even in our minutes about
saying like you know we're worried about
the cost but the cost is also lower so I
mean can you guys address that yeah I
mean Co cost will go down with adult use
we can support um greater economies of
scale on the manufacturing side um
because we're making more products
generally in those
facilities so it you know we've seen
that in in all all the markets over time
as pricing has gotten more competitive
with more companies out there um and
that flows through to therapeutic as
well do you have any idea like based on
what's in Massachusetts like what's that
look like as it translates to the
patient
cost uh we're we're down about
50% uh at the counter than where we were
in
2018 when adult use sales
started when you say down 50% you're
talking about sales or amount of
customers patients uh that was just the
the price that a customer would pay um
compression yeah patience
yep Mr
chairman kale thank you Mr chairman so H
how many of these um experts that are
doing the talking to people at at your
locations are
doctors well I'll introduce you to Dr
Davids well is he at the location yeah
I'm I'm actually you know on site seeing
patients interviewing patients and um
I've been doing that since the day we
opened and well I'm talking about all
these all these stores OB obviously you
can't be at every school so how how how
many of your employees that are actually
giving information about medical
doctors I can answer that I guess so the
answer is um the answer is none at our
at our location um at a at our Peak
Point um when we had one facility in
marac um and we hadn't opened in Chai
Chester yet we had three full-time
individuals each performing consults
about six seven a day one an hour
essentially where we give give patients
that time um that was almost 10% of our
entire staff devoted just for that it
would be absolutely unaffordable in that
scale and providing that quantity of
service to pay a physician to do it that
would drastically have increased our
costs if you know 10% of our staff were
positions making that that kind of a
salary you know I I understand that
increaseing cost my question would be
maybe to the AG's office is there a
liability in the State Franchise model
if if we have people giving medical
doctors can I can I ask for
clarification and do younger did I say
correctly you may chime in this too I so
I heard if testimony correctly that if a
doctor makes a recommendation to a
patient and is is a patient I guess the
appropriate term in for the
therapeutic all right it so the doctor
makes the recommendation the atc's are
required to follow the recommendation of
that doctor so correct how does number
one how does the ATC know what the
doctor's recommendation is when that
patient comes inside the store then the
other side of that is um I was under the
impression that the
doctors aren't necessarily able to make
that recommendation under the because of
the federal law which is another thing
our federal delegation perhaps should uh
address but yeah I mean I mean I think
that when we're counseling patients at
least when I'm counseling patients we
definitely talk about you know the
federal you know that it's federally
illegal that there are certainly you
know jobs in which you at least in the
current state that you can be you know
let go from if you're test positive for
cannabis all the sort of legality of it
all and I think we can give General
recommendations but also you know it's a
challenge like we were mentioning
earlier that um I've never been to an
ATC I can't go into an ATC so it it
makes it you know I'd say these are the
type of products that you know I other
patients have found helpful you know the
literature supports you know this CBD
versus THC ratio um but but I also don't
know how that information would get to
you except for I tell the patient the
patient tells you um my my understanding
is the patient's not taking their notes
uh it's not in writing right it's not
like it's not like written down write
something down yeah it it doesn't help
happen a lot but what the patient will
come in with a a written form from their
doctor stating you know please provide
low THC High CBD products for this
patient um sometimes you know they'll
mention uh lowd dose Edibles versus high
dose Edibles that you know they're just
concerned of the patient having a bad
reaction particularly if they're new to
the Cannabis so but it doesn't happen a
lot say low what is that's that's vague
I mean it should say it's an amount and
when someone says low a doctor said
writes it down yeah the doctor on this
commission but different doctor writes
it down yeah but I mean you can't expect
the position that's not really versed in
the endocannabinoid system to understand
like what's the difference between 5
milligrams of CBD and 10 milligrams of
CBD well they're making the
recommendation yeah but that's why they
say low dose or high dose you know I and
then that's up to the discretion of the
dispensaries to you know kind of tease
that out well if a doctor's recommending
someone do something I assume that the
doctor did their research I think that's
a fair M it would be malpractice
otherwise absolutely so a doctor's
making a recommendation they have low
THC I'm just asking if someone comes in
with that written down what is the you
what do you consider low THD to me I'd
say anything under five milligrams you
know we have we have even 1.5 milligram
mint THC so we could start something off
with that just say do one mint twice a
day you're not going to get any
psychoactivity from that amount but it
might help with inflammation help with
pain you know so we'll start from there
and then like Matt said a lot of times
they'll come back and if it was if it
was helpful they'll say hey that was
really helpful if they need more pain
control we can up it a little bit and
tell them okay or or give them a Sal or
a cream that's non- psychoactive but
isn't that against what the doctor may
have recommended well I think the
doctor's initial recommendation you do
start with that and then you build from
there based upon medical knowledge and I
thought you had to follow the doctor's
recommendation so how would you bu you
can't build on that and I I guess what
do you do when it's not in R you just
rely on what the patient says well also
we they do sign a waiver the patients do
send a waiver letting us talk to their
doctor so I've actually called the
doctor's office a few times times and
said you know Mrs Jones we started her
off with 5 milligram of THC and 10
milligrams of CBD um she's getting some
relief but is it okay if we up the THC a
little bit because THC really is good
for pain control CBD is good for anxiety
a little bit an inflammatory for pain
but um so we I we will call the doctor's
office like I said it doesn't happen a
lot it's just it's just the nature of
the game like you said there a lot of
the Physicians areen educated on
cannabis and I guess so that
conversation happens behind the scenes I
understand it's Hipp it's private so
it's not I suppose from a regulatory
perspective how would our friends in
liquor ever know a doctor may have
recommended X and the atc's doing y I'm
not saying you're doing that I'm just
saying in theory if you want them to
violate the law no none of you have not
of course no one would do that but how
do they ever enforce
that or how would they ever
know that's a good point currently with
only So currently with only three
dispensaries we have a fax line we keep
open and our contact info is available
on the DHHS website we get calls from
the Physicians or providers or we get
emails or faxes in which case we reach
out and have that conversation it's not
super common but we absolutely have it
happen but I guess if you let's say the
doctor recommended low THC but person
working at the register decide to oh you
want the higher th stuff
sure how would how would that
everle specific recommendation we're
required to follow it some of the
recommendations may not be specific
enough but could could have a Pati
Gateway where you loog Massachusetts you
have to log in the gateway to make sure
they're registered patients and you
could have notes in there just like any
other medical system where this is the
provider's notes um
do a doctor would a doctor be
comfortable being entered into that
database I mean it's it's going like my
name's on every paper that I send when I
certify someone anyway so it's already
there but I I would say you know talking
about sort of the legality and medical
malpractice I mean I think s most people
who are at least even in my clinic I
think are not making a recommendation
they're saying you meet the state
criteria for medical cannabis I don't
see any contraindications so you're not
you know having some sort of acute
psychiatric episode you're not actively
abusing other drugs um and that's all
they're saying they're not making a
recommendation at all because they're
not recommending that therapy they're
just saying you meet the criteria I'll
sign this paper and so when we do
recommendation the only thing I think
that's a challenge with with what what's
being said here is that that is
requiring that the patient takes what I
say and brings it to you uh which I you
know is is a is a challenge right
because I could be recommending things
all day long and unless they print that
note out or take whatever I've given
them to you that never happens um and I
don't really know workaround for that
with HIPPA and some of these other
challenges so if a patient just walks in
off the street with no paper from any
doctor but they have the therapeutic
card what's the policy of each each of
the atcs when it comes to selling a
therapeutic
product well we encourage them to sign
up for a consultation and discuss
options with them uh but they are
legally authorized to purchase products
so they may do so so even so that a
patient that doesn't get any
consultation there's no information from
the doctor they still can purchase the
product without the benefit
of I mean you can do that in pharmacy
now you can decline consultation too I
think there's a reality to the fact that
some patients have been using cannabis
medically for longer than it has been
legal and other patients have been
participating in programs in other
states and have moved to New Hampshire
they already know what works for them
them the concern is for people who are
new to therapeutic cannabis uh and it's
analogous to the concern of what about
people who are new to cannabis generally
and and I don't mean to I'm not giving
anyone a hard time I just one thing that
that's required me to support any policy
is that whatever rules that are there
are enforc it can reasonably be enforced
so one of the concerns I have is the
enforcement side of that especially if
if it was moved under liquor so I'm not
saying anyone's doing wrong it's just in
theory as this industry
grows it increases the probability of
having a bad actor yeah well it seems to
me that in any scenario of of the
franchise store is selling to registered
patients at minimum they're going to
have to be able to verify that the
individual is a registered patient so
they're going to have to be able to
access the registry the card alone is I
mean we have to check and make sure
they're actually in the system that card
may have been revoked so I mentioned the
idea of possibility of crime selling
their product or allowing it to be sold
at other stores that you know other
retail stores basically still following
all the regulations you know for
therapeutic use in that case would you
would it be appropriate maybe to have
perhaps in that agreement what you would
require any vendor or franchise to to
follow to sell your product I mean is
that something that could be done
without the need I guess for laws or
regulation
I'll leave for anyone yeah to the you
can have a
contract that stipulates a certain level
of education for staff at that store um
you can provide them educational
materials when you deliver the products
um if you're not the regulator you can't
actually audit them but certainly you
can put some guard rails in place that
you know good business people would
follow and and on a cultivation question
question uh I assume all all three of
the ATC businesses I know there's more
stores but each of each of those
entities are cultivating correct yeah
yeah now would would these entities each
be able to increase the amount that
they're
cultivating so yeah I I think we could
certainly expand assuming there's a a
clear path for lure under adult use
because it's a multi-year um process to
design and construct more space so right
now the cultivation for therapeutic but
could you increase the amount of
cultivation to have so Prime doesn't
have any recreational brand yet but it
could have it could perhaps make a
recreational product as well and
increase that and that could be
distributed throughout any franchise
y
y thanks um another question that I have
is as you know there's more access
potentially for patients and with
different limits and potency um you know
I think right now geographically things
are pretty separate and so it's less
convenient let's say for X patient to go
to this ATC and then to go to another
ATC but as that changed obviously I
don't want to think anybody is diverting
their medication however um I think that
there would likely be some Market uh for
a higher potency um product um and so is
there anything currently in place or
what is the potential for something to
be in place to say if you know this
person goes to this place with their
medical card and gets x amount of
cannabis at this like higher potency to
go you know now 15 or 20 minutes down
the road to the next place and and get
the same is there anything to right now
to stop
that yeah anyone take that so yes there
currently is something in place to stop
that um basically the patient records
are securely shared with the Department
of Health and Human Services who
monitors and basically looks at what was
dispensed and um essentially if a
patient is being is purchasing more than
two ounces in a 10day period which is
the current limit um they are sent a
warning letter if they do it again they
lose their
card so they basically lose the right to
purchase and be a New Hampshire patient
if they are exceeding that limit so but
that's not monitored at the ATC level
that's monitored at the HSS level so we
monitor it separately but we cannot see
what's dispensed by other atcs that is
something that could be integrated into
a larger system but is a bit
exorbitantly expensive at the scale of
only having three Stores um one thing
I'll point out is that with legal states
all around us any adult who wants to go
buy cannabis in quantity can go from
store to store and do so there's
absolutely nothing stopping them from
doing that today right but the but the
potency is very different right like
what the legal the legal limit for what
you're able to purchase for at an ATC
Now versus what we proposed potentially
would be available for adult use is not
the same correct for edible products
yeah okay so normally it's for edible
products um if I may in the sense that
um with an edible products they're often
limited to say five milligrams a dose
but someone could eat multiple of those
doses to get the same overall dosage is
is kind of a normal thing for inhalable
products like like flour or vape
cartridges those are generally not
limited in any of the states around us
for
potency Chief thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for your testimony a few
questions uh is it uh fair to say that
based on your testimony that in the
states that have legalized uh the retail
sale of cannabis products that the um
revenue or is it the total number of
patients has diminished I think you you
cited in Massachusetts by 50% um is that
accurate or can you provide some
clarifying information about that so the
50% that Mr poock referenced was a
decrease in price uh not patients or
sales so we actually have uh Dan Smith
behind us and this may be an appropriate
time for him to briefly present the data
in his report which speaks directly to
your question of the decline in patient
registration
the decline in medical program sales and
how states have generally dealt with
that so would that be acceptable well I
I would appreciate I think we have that
in written testimony perhaps in U in the
era of efficiency of time we can we can
read that but generally is it fair to
say that there's been a diminishment of
registration and sales uh in some cases
significant in states that have
legalized retail sale of cannabis would
that be fair to say that's correct okay
thank you uh follow-up question now um
in states where cannabis has been
legalized uh
some recent research suggests that the
menu of products being sold by atc's in
those States mimic um and duplicate the
same products being sold in the retail
outlets would that be fair to say some
products are the same in medical and
adult use systems other products are
more unique to therapeutic
systems but is it fair to say that uh in
many cases the products are actually
duplicate the same name same product
numbers same contents sold in retail uh
as opposed to the same product same menu
um with the same name sold
therapeutically would that be fair to
say that's correct okay um can you offer
uh an an and I think I may know the
answer but I I'll ask you can you offer
a an explanation as to why New Hampshire
therapeutic products are significantly
more expensive than those sold in Maine
or
Massachusetts yes so in Maine first of
all uh there is much less regulation of
medical cannabis in Maine they've had
the law since
1999 uh every caregiver was allowed to
grow six plants for up to five patients
and if you're patient yourself that
meant that you could grow 36 plants uh
several years ago the caregivers got
organized and fought for their right to
open
storefronts very different than our New
Hampshire system it led to a
proliferation of storefronts in Maine uh
a lot of people do not realize that
those storefronts sell cannabis that is
not required to be independently lab
tested so it is a risk I think that is
not well known or understood and it's
only recently being reported as the main
office of cannabis policy attempts to
get that regulation through the
legislature and we hope they succeed
because the health risks associated with
mold pesticides heavy metals being
present in cannabis are real risks it's
an important reason to legalize in our
opinion for adult use as well as medical
use to make sure that all of these
products do not contain contaminants
that would be harmful to patients or to
Consumers so uh the regulatory burdens
complying with complex regulations in
New Hampshire for example I mean in New
Hampshire we can't uh grow outdoors or
even in green houses under our current
rules all all the plants have to be
grown indoors under the lights and that
is the most expensive way to grow
cannabis we could produce it somewhat
more cheaply if we could grow outdoors
or in green houses uh every every Rule
and regulation adds a little bit of cost
here and there so we're not claiming
that they're unreasonable but relative
to what Maine is dealing with um yeah
very different and in Massachusetts
they've you know very different but
they've Chief uh I I've operated medical
uh in Massachusetts since 2015 we are
highly regulated in Massachusetts but um
in large part due to expanding the
business with recreational sales we are
able to realize significant efficiencies
and therefore decrease our cost
structure and pass that cost along to uh
the medical
patients thank you so uh is it fair to
say then based on your uh recent
response that you were in favor of a
more regulated program in which uh
testing uh um of cannabis products uh is
in place to ensure Public Health would
that be fair to say absolutely okay so
currently what is the testing protocols
that you use uh and it may be very
lengthy so I I in the interest of
efficiency for the commission perhaps
you can provide um the Commission in a
printed form what the testing protocol
is but do you have a testing protocol to
test for uh a an established number of
chemicals diluents um and pesticides and
so forth yes those have been determined
by rule by the Department of Health and
Human Services all of our products every
batch has to be tested uh we test for
the cannabinoid content uh the tarpine
content those are both displayed on on
the labels and on the menus and we also
test for all of the contaminants that
are required to test for by rule and the
limits are prescribed by Rule Do you
happen to know which testing facility is
used uh for this sampling yeah there's
only one lab in New Hampshire currently
providing that
service thank you and um has there ever
been to your knowledge uh any rejection
of any batch or sample as a result of uh
testing that produced a result positive
for any of the listed contaminants or
pesticides oh yes uh mold in particular
uh when you're growing an Agricultural
Product and curing it and processing it
indoors mold is your enemy and there are
of it's probably the most common
contaminant you will find in unregulated
cannabis uh so yes we mold mold a batch
will get rejected for mold and that is
part
of what
happens are you aware of uh generally uh
the number of batches or samples um
perhaps in a year that have been
rejected I have no idea okay 10%
10% okay thank you um now one couple
final uh questions um with respect to uh
adherence to
DHHS rules and regulations for patients
and as it was previously mentioned uh op
opportunities to circumvent as the chair
indicated um those rules and regulations
do you uh know how many times if any uh
any of the your companies have
self-reported any of these issues to
Hampshire the labs actually send a
report the lab Nelson analytical sends
the lab report directly to the state so
they have a copy of that so there's no
way we can somehow fudge results or
alter results so the state gets their
own separate copy um and then you know
we we'll we'll we'll pull that that
batch if necessary based upon like Matt
said mold or if there's any chance of
heavy metals or something like that
which is rare but usually like Matt said
it's usually mold and it's about 8 to
10% yes thank you um I I've actually
switched rails here a little bit I'm uh
focusing on um patients and
circumvention of DHS rules with respect
to patients as I think there was
previous testimony by you or a member of
your group regarding the fact that your
company's report to DHHS when you
suspect that there is a patient that is
trying to circumvent the rules
correct do you happen to have a record
of how many of those self-reports were
made uh Chief we happy to follow up with
the commission on that it does happen I
was copied on one a couple weeks ago
does happen thank you I think it would
be important for the commission to to
see generally um what that frequency may
be thank you and one one final question
are are you aware uh or any of you aware
of a recent study of chronic pain uh and
association with cannabis legislation
that deals with uh patients in the US
veterans and health administration that
shows between 2005 and
2019 that reflects a significant
comorbidity with cannabis use disorder
and and legalization are you aware of
that recent
study off hand I am not thank you I ask
a question I I think I hope we're all in
agreement with you support Recon not
that we don't want the black market to
grow right now I one thing I noticed in
every single state that has gone down
this path they the Black Market has
grown now one of the reasons for that is
well they tend to make the same mistake
over and over again so I don't sure it's
as surprising also allocating of
resources I think one thing we'll have a
benefit of is liquor enforcement well
we'll have a law enforcement agency on
day one that will have a directive to
actually address Black Market issues but
in this it's not a bill number this
working model that I know I know you
guys have a copy of it we're trying to
reduce that or mitigate the black market
problem as much as we can is there
anything in here do you think
uh that should be changed in respect to
that I mean I think limiting the amount
of stores
obviously what helps the black market
issue because you don't have an
oversaturated Market keeping the price
low is there anything that you would
recommend that we could add to this
perhaps to help mitigate a black
market now I think we all agree with
that goal I think that's the most
important policy goal associated with
adult use legalization is to displace
the illicit market and transition to uh
effectively regulated market so the the
tax or fee burden whatever it is called
is part of that uh a licensing process
that that moves efficiently uh you know
the ability the sooner businesses can
get licensed and start growing and start
selling cannabis the sooner we can start
transitioning people away from the
regulated market so I think some people
will look at the 24mon timeline and and
say that that that is
you know not going to be a way to get um
that might be counter to the idea of
eliminating the unregulated market
quickly of course that's a policy
decision for for you all to make um I
will comment briefly on the idea that
the elicit Market has proliferated in in
States uh that have legalized adult use
cannabis so it's true in one sense and
it's not true in another sense uh stands
to reason that when Colorado became the
first state to legalize cannabis
that some individuals decided to buy oh
cannabis is legal here that means I can
buy a house and grow 500 plants in it
and sell them uh ship them to New
Hampshire and sell it uh the evidence
overwhelmingly suggests that consumers
in states that legalize adult use
cannabis if there is a dispensary near
them they will buy from the dispensary
uh and if there is a regulated market in
their state that works the regulated
market will get most of the business
business hom grow is one factor in that
some people just grow their own and
don't go to a store or buy from the
illicit Market uh
but what primarily is happening when we
hear the the the illicit markets
expanding it's criminal actors are
taking or using the cover of
legalization to produce cannabis in a
state and Export it to states where
cannabis is not yet legal so with every
state that brings online a a a regulated
market I think that problem becomes less
of a problem because the more states
that have their own retail markets it is
no longer lucrative to ship cannabis
from Colorado to New Hampshire if New
Hampshire has its its own stores but is
there any recommendation that you have
any of you have specifically on how to
mitigate a black market from it's it's
already here right but it's the
expansion of it is really what is the
biggest concern that I have yeah so I
think you know the cost structures
imposed on a business directly impact
pricing to customers Black Market
doesn't have uh fees or taxes um so I
think the lower the cost burden on
businesses the lower the price will be
to customers and the less incentive a
customer would have to go to the black
market um I I would argue you know you
look at a state like Vermont or
Massachusetts or Maine all that Revenue
that's in the program that is revenue
that would have been in the black market
so you are taking out some of that
Revenue um
so I I don't see New Hampshire being a
exporting cannabis State that's you know
Oklahoma California right now um so I
think PR price you know things that
drive cost and then price are going to
be the biggest factors the state can uh
consider for reducing the lcit market
let me clarify my my concern I'm
concerned about the black market in New
Hampshire all right the other states
that's up to their law enforcement to
deal with that y because when you say
you don't want us to be I don't know
exporting is the right term but yeah a
high percentage of our liquor sales are
to outut ofate Residents I don't I think
under the right model you can mimic that
with cannabis yes so I wouldn't say
because someone's a consumer is buying
in bulk necessarily means you're
supporting a black market correct yeah
but I guess my my concern is I want to
make sure that you don't have that
problem grow so just lowering the
the franchise fee I guess is the only
thing I'm hearing which I I I get that
but franchise fees and Licensing fees
will directly impact the cost that a
business has and thus the price that
they charge and the the primary reason a
person purchases not in a regulated
system is because of price um
that's yeah so my next question is
probably not not a great question uh
this is my this is my last question for
a while promise so I I see on on the
last page there was a suggestion that
the the uh therapeutic products be
exempt from the 15% franchise
fee correct which I I understand right
now it's not subject to that right but
if let's say it was that the therapeutic
product was subject to that franchise
feed
um what other type of Revenue do you
think that the atcs would gain in this
under the retail model because I think
obviously the retail sales will help you
the Freer Market you have the C
increased cultivation and more
distribution spots so would it be fair
to still have that
15% it's it's more our view is that for
medical products generally there's not
extra fees or taxes so these are sick
people and it's very common in in
cannabis to the extent that that is
important for the commission to
understand that medical
products you know taxes are what are
used in other states are not taxed um
whether it's cannabis or pharmaceutical
drugs at the pharmacy I guess my my
point is there's a lot of benefits to
the ATC industry in this working model
right being now for-profit as opposed to
a nonprofit more distribution points
more cultivation Revenue uh this
obviously retail sales why would the
15% for therapeutic sales be a problem
just asking right it it would not be a
problem for our business this was a
suggestion especially if therapeutic
products are sold at all franchise
stores that those products should be
fuse
oh thank you Mr chair thank you Vice
chairman you know U the senator was just
asking how you you thought you could
bring down costs don't don't you think
maybe lobbying for like um energy
Independence would bring down costs
isn't energy your production phase like
one of your biggest costs that gets
passed on to the tax or the the
patients yes I mean I mean that that'd
be one way you guys could suggest we
lower cost like yeah as we mentioned we
would like to be able to grow outdoors
and in green houses and uh there is an
LSR for a bill that that would allow
that represent okay I'll be quick all
right great Pati okay so you know I like
to tell stories and uh so one of our big
issues here in New Hampshire is uh we
would have on any given day someone will
walk into our liquor store and say why
don't you sell beer here where's the
beer and we had made that decision to
bifurcate that
industry I believe they made it and I
wasn't in the room back in 1933 but I
think they made that decision uh because
they knew that distill was a much higher
alcohol content had a higher and needed
to be well
regulated and I say this in that you
have absolutely convinced me
undoubtedly that you provide a very
important service to our
constituents okay um that having uh
someone to consult with and really
understand what they should be buying
makes absolutely perfect sense to me
okay what doesn't make sense to me is to
try to blend that into our liquor stores
slm marijuana stores right that we would
never we would always say no you got to
go to a professional for that our
marijuana stores our
franchises would be barred from giving
any medical advice they cannot mention
anything about
medicine so to have a handful or maybe
all of them have a separate quarter
separate window separate thing that um
that now all of a sudden there are set
different rules like it's not tax but
it's maybe more regulated in other ways
I don't know that would create conflict
within the stores that would can create
incredible confusion it would be what do
you mean you don't sell Medical in this
store
dead the other one I went to dead okay
that's exactly why we do not sell beer
in liquor stores we don't want to create
anyone conv we want consistency
consistency of the product consistency
of the
advice okay so as far as I'm concerned
right now you guys play a very important
part in the marketplace because there
are consumers who are not going to want
to walk into an adult store retail store
they want to walk into a place that is
going to give them good medical
advice and so therefore in my mind how
do you merge those how do you how can
you have some have it and some not when
right now you what you have now in this
current model you pay no
tax and there's no way we're going to
have inside a marijuana store oh a
separate window this this is that's a
tax-free
window but you got to go do this no that
is the last thing we want to do to our
consumers is to create that confusion
believe so um I I think the feedback I'd
provide to that because I understand
where you're coming from um Senator Hunt
is sorry representative is um
basically um in that scenario in in a
situation where we're selling to
therapeutic patients if it's generally
the same products being sold and we're
spending extra money on the educational
services that is a cost but if there is
if they're sold for the same price
because it costs the same to produce and
there's the same tax on it why would
sign up TA you have no tax right now
well currently we pay for the program
the general fund doesn't fund it so we
pay any extra costs required to regulate
to regulate us this is the licensing so
as as far as any extra cost that the
therapeutic cannabis program and would
would actually take on we pay anything
extra they requireed to run their office
print the cards pay the fees all of that
type of thing so if we regardless if the
cost of therapeutic is the same as non-
therapeutic there's no incentive for
someone to go pay their physician to see
them pay for a card go through all that
rigar roll to access that that that
medical guidance you'd be likely that
we'd
simply doing without that that would be
my expectation so that's the reason that
that would be of value so so if we were
to remove the cap and that there was 50
atc's rather than in
four would that mean the fees would be
actually less than 15% of the retail
price come on how much can those those
fees really be I I guess we'll have to
look at the HHS budget to see what your
fees are but I mean you're really saying
that's going to represent the 15%
tax I'm not sure I will tell you that
there's been some misunderstanding about
this the law that created the
therapeutic cannabis program requires
the program to be Revenue neutral the
Department of Health and Human Services
required to set fees that cover the
costs of Regulation and they do so so um
I think the outcry that you will hear
from this uh if if patients are uh
subjected to a 15% fee you will hear an
outcry from from them much more than you
would from us uh it's an understanding
and I mean there are a few states that
apply a very small tax to medical
cannabis but the vast majority of States
out there do not ta tax medical cannabis
at all and do tax cannabis sales to
non-registered patients let's clarify
this we're not that that's a that 15%
fees on the gross sales under for the
franchise right that's like a worldy
basically you're paying for the
franchise and there's also a benefit
that each store would have because the
the state the franchise or is going to
do some of the marketing side of things
with that with that being said though I
understand that if the 15% fee applied
to a therapeutic grade product there's
other Revenue sources that your your
businesses would all be gaining and for
that reason if the if you want I suppose
it's decision of each of your stores if
you want to pass that cost onto the
consumer and raise the price or your
patients and want to raise the price
that's a decision you can make but you
have other Revenue sources that I
believe representative hunt believes
will be greater than perhaps that 15%
fee and I think I'm I kind of agree that
there's so many other opportunities for
to generate Revenue that's being created
for the atcs that that 15% fee shouldn't
cause the patients to have to pay more
than they're paying now
I think in that scenario in that
scenario we would do our best to keep
prices low this was our recommendation
based on what we've seen work in other
markets that we directly participate in
and a lot of these other markets I from
what I understand in other states
they've all run into similar problems
so so apologize for being late to the
main but um I was a little I'm a little
confused by the conversation because my
understanding in the legislation the the
draft we have there that medicinal
dispensaries medical dispensaries will
not be charged at 15% is that correct as
it written yes okay and then my
understanding was however we were
providing a path for medicinal
dispensaries to move from nonprofit to
four profit entities but if they choose
to be a franchise my my thought was that
again my understanding was it would be a
separate facility and that facility
would be subject to the 15% tax is that
we when we we weren't going to co-mingle
funds or co-mingle buildings they were
going to be separate distinct entities
within could be under one corporate
umbrella but two separate facilities one
of which which sold medical which was
not subject and the money was over there
and one over here was the franchise
which was subject to the 15 that was my
understanding of what we were talking
about in previous meetings is that now
changed my understanding is if if Prime
which doesn't exist anymore wanted to
keep its prime store in theory they
could but if they want to join the
retail
Market this is this is the conditions
it's going to have to they're going to
you're not going to have two registers
one for retail one for they're going be
physically separated they can be
completely separate stores but they're
not going to be the same buildings not
going to be one building and is door a
and door B again without getting into
that detail I'm I just want to be clear
again my understanding was it was a
separate facility whether the details of
whether it's one building with a with a
wall down in the middle I don't know but
again one of of those facilities the
medical would not be subject to the 15%
tax so therefore they could help keep
their pricing low the second facility or
premise would be uh premises would be a
for-profit facility as a franchisee of
the Liquor Commission subject to all the
rules and regulations of the Liquor
Commission and it would be subject to
the 15% tax that's my understanding as
well that's what this the working draft
says I just want to make sure we're all
on the same page that's what the draft
says the hypothetical that I just ran by
before you dve was if they weren't if
they just had to become if they wanted
to become a franchise store they would
just be that but the really it's The
Branding side of thing so Prime's
product is really the brand long-term
brand and if they were to if they were
permitted to sell that product or to any
franchisee throughout the state you
would have a therapeutic I guess grade
product that you still need a car to buy
and that would increase their points of
distribution rather than have this kind
of store off to the side and all that
they would technically any franchise you
could sell it if they you want the
franch I'm sorry I'm we're now
comingling medical grade product with
Cons with recreational product in the
same building what it was just a
suggestion rather than have a separate
store because the the problem is is The
Branding of what the store looks like
when you're when you pull in the parking
lot you going to have and that's exactly
why I thought it was going to be two
separate buildings for two separate
marketing messages now Prime may be able
to get and an ATC may be able to get
their their manufacturing license and
sell to both the retail side and the
medical side if they choose to If the
product on the on the meets all of our
criteria um I don't think we should
restrict that but one but if they sell
product a over here and sell product a
over here and Retail and medical versus
retail the retail is going to be subject
to the tax the one on this side is not
even though it may be the same exact
product sold in two different types of
stores medical franchise
well you can be done that way I was the
hypothetical I'm posing and I'm just
trying to use what I think is common
sense if my doctor recommending I take a
certain dose of something in theory I
could get that dose satisfied at the
recreational store I might have to eat
more than one whatever or have more than
one I I my point is I don't think that
people are going to drive very far if
they don't have to and they can just do
the math so the idea is I know the ATC
are worried about their long-term
liability so I'm trying to offer you
perhaps just some thoughts to think
about if they I think that's going to
happen I think the therap PE Market to
be hit no matter what retail business
you do but allowing if we're going to do
the franchise model I think it's going
to be complicated having separate stores
well I think actually I think it's
cleaning right again because you're not
mixing books you're not mixing anything
right you're not mixing employees we had
this conversation about the medical
conversation that occurs in a medical
facility that doesn't occur in a retail
facility you have a you have an employe
who's on one day walking on this side
and the second day going on this side
I'm not I think that's just a nightmare
but then why have a dual license let
them have a separate facility that's a
retail if they choose to do that they
can have a separate retail facility they
can work out the details behind their
doors as far as their profit margins and
stuff but again which on can pay 15% on
the retail PS 15% sales out of the
retail store franchise store pays 15%
yeah they can certainly qualify to join
up to be a franchise right that's what
I'm saying but otherwise they but forget
about the medical part because you can't
that no employee can say that this is
medical it's illegal for them to say
again they said they give they give
advice we of some sort we could under
the franchise agreement perhaps
specify the medical advice has to come
from their treating
position and and
not can't so if I may just as a point of
information we want but we don't want we
don't want the retail store giving the
medical advice if a doctor goes Rogan
gives advice that's that's I mean I I
agree we don't want the liability of
them giving medical advice under this
under again another even if you're a
doctor and qualify to we still don't
want that on the
stage so if I may just as a point of
information the current draft the
current draft that we were asked to
comment on does not envision atc's
operating franchise stores it has a
separate definition of cannabis retail
store that means an alternative
treatment center licensed to purchase
cannabis and sell it to Consumers so the
current draft just want to be clear
about that the current draft does allows
atc's to operate retail stores that are
not franchise stores and we're open to
being part of the way it's written or
what you're talking about depending on
details I that was the language I asked
suggested to you to change though I mean
there's going to be a lot of red pens to
draft you see the Chiefs I already I
should have seen what he has going on
it's the whole thing's almost
right I gotta smile on you Mr chair just
circling back on your uh questions with
respect to uh the illicit market and uh
what the uh folks testifying today would
do um perhaps um an explanation as to a
little bit generally uh in terms of the
cost factor that goes into your products
so is it fair to say that um licensing
and testing represents a a portion I
don't expect you to give us the
percentage but a portion of the cost per
products that you sell would that be
accurate correct so licensing fees
testing uh storefront
um as well real
estate yes right rental fees right uh
and with respect to
employees um Social Security withholding
workers comp so forth and so on right
and
so in terms of the illicit Market are
you generally aware uh as to whether or
not illicit Growers and Distributors of
marijuana pay any of those fees I not
that I'm aware of they are required to
pay federal taxes under code 280e I
doubt that very many of them do uh but I
I would say they do impose they do take
on another cost which is the risk of
being prosecuted for a felony that's the
primary mechanism that dri drives up the
price on the illicit Market whereas the
the conditions you mentioned drive up
prices in a regulated market so would it
be fair to say then that in in terms of
a pure economic point of view the cost
of their product uh is always going to
be less than whatever uh is sold in a
legalized or in an ATC model I disagree
with that entirely and and we can look
at illicit Market estimates uh over the
last 20 years and we can look at prices
within the regulated market as regulated
markets mature there's always an initial
period we always begin with high demand
and low Supply and as the supply catches
up with demand there is a a bit of a
flipping that happens and there's an
inevitable decrease in prices uh across
the market as Mr poock mentioned there's
been a substantial decrease in prices
across the Massachusetts Market Maine
has experienced similar Vermont has not
yet because they've only had about a
year of retail sales but it it has
happened in every state the price begins
relatively high and it comes down as
Supply catches up with demand Chief with
um with AIC efficiencies automated
equipment scale you can uh sort of
offset some of those additional costs
that regulated businesses
have understood but uh in General's uh
sense and it's fair to say then that in
in the various states that have
legalized the illicit Market has
actually expanded um to the extent that
the legislature and Oregon uh in a
previous session in
21 um appropriated an additional $25
million to address the illicit Market at
inorg aren't you aware of that I am
aware of that Chief and I would make the
distinction that what Oregon was facing
was an issue of growing more cannabis
that can reasonably sold in the state
the problem is I understood it was not
that Oregon residents were buying from
the illicit Market but that cannabis was
being grown in Oregon under the guise of
legalization and ship to States like New
Hampshire think that's an important
distinction is there any further
questions for
the
visitors see on thanks guys thank you
Senator thank you all okay so uh we do
have next week is already scheduled
right I will not be here but I'm sure
you won't miss me and uh
journ